assalamu alaikum wa rahmatullah wa
better character brothers and sisters
hope you all doing well obviously there
is a challenge that's being set up
- for charity and the links are below
now my challenge is the onion lemon and
salt challenge and obviously now I
thought I'll prepared with you guys
instead of getting everything ready and
I can show you might cut in the onion
skills that I used to work in an Indian
takeaway before is it yes thank you
laptops is all you know I mean honey's a
scardy I'm telling you buddy's gonna be
one big box yeah about 40 bang bang
anyway yeah don't try this at home
please if you are under 16 should I say
legally look mom check this out yeah
look at this professional off the videos
gonna be cutting onion yeah of course
well show them okay do a lot that's
that's the onion yet and all see we cut
our lemon in half yeah yeah you need to
sharpen this everyone other metal shop
in this no right here is their kitchen
Yesenia all right now yes I'm also going
to go get the knife because it's not
sharp enough so as you can see we're
with the sisters the onion is ready our
lemon is ready on not this one just try
it man no no dismiss the shot across
look at it reasonably now but with the
sisters why is your mouth worried this
ain't gonna be tasty yeah because I'm
hungry alright we'll cut the onion to
the little pieces I'm not going to eat
it all because I can't eat it all
I think that enough
yeah 20 more nice fun hey sure now I'm
going to cut into little pieces my
breasts gonna be stinking all day you
know let's go messaging if I'm resting
so onion nothing you've got excited okay
okay okay
now the onions are ready now first we
put a bit of salt to give it that flavor
brothers a lot of salt we can't see I
can't see it from the board our law so I
will put some lemon now there's my
special recipe it's coming up okay oh if
it's effective eyes not with a finger
drag quite emotional for me actually
okay now I'm going to eat all this
don't tease me nice watch why you know
I'm not checking notes right
it is nice glossy or it's not really a
challenge then is it like in the water
please
why no open yes kicking in darn it my
brothers before I nominate Gordon to war
blast zone yeah you said you said
yourself and you said that's a little
bit as well no what a cool yeah well
here brothers and sisters I'm nominating
this guy next to me Musa Edna
we're going to uh nominate him to eat
chili and as you guys all look actually
the whole thing was about chili right
here but as you guys know I like to be a
bit different and creative and a bit
more easier and a bit more easier I
nominate Musa to eat Chili's what's it
called death in Chili's left fiery ones
in fiery chilies but what sounds are
really good for you guys
and this is something really special now
this challenge goes add our man in
Ronnie bin man soo yeah
no Chili's not an easy vote and I'm like
no no chicken roll the chicken challenge
I challenge high talent Imran to do this
to do exactly this we've gotta cross
cause he loves garlic sauce
I want Imran and I challenge him to eat
a piece of chicken like this and it has
to do exactly this he has to eat
everything that's a challenge in brown
brothers and sisters share this as much
as you can make sure moussala donation
sauce here okay but Imran I challenge
him to have a full piece of chicken
here's the thing yeah the reason why
this is a challenge you can find out
from Imran yourself if he chooses to
tell you guys but trust me yeah this is
worse than everyone eating 10 chilies
yeah this is a mad thing yeah so
obviously chili is gonna be hard for me
it's for charity this is crazy
a piece of chicken tell him no it's not
going to be cut it up already looking or
nice lack of chips has to be a chicken a
piece of chicken
I also bother the sister please donate
below and challenge every single one of
you as well but not the chicken the
chicken is opening with him right
because it's a special guy I challenge
you guys to eat onion lemon and salt and
also chili if you can you can choose in
between but um don't forget about the
link and surely I don't hold the whole
reason we're doing this whole campaign
thing and obviously was started by a
brother called yaha yeah a shot at his
brother Roy - ah idea I mean his name is
Yahoo she do so he basically started
this thing um where you know he saw the
ALS ice bucket challenge and he wanted
to start something similar for the
Muslims
so obviously the money that will be
raised will inch other go towards Gaza
so obviously please do you know donate
and obviously we're doing this to raise
awareness and obviously going to be a
bit fun a bit entertainment for you guys
you don't really see the side of us
normally where you see the mean side to
us yeah what I mean is I literally mosh
so yeah but let's instead make sure you
tweet Facebook whatever you can to get
Imran to eat this channel if you want
him run to eat this trust me you're
gonna have to bug him like there's no
tomorrow and what you're gonna call us
he's gonna be like brothers now when
opinion is called and you're not fitting
up his cause for 24 hours message him
and tell him brother a man we want you
to get a piece of chicken fried chicken
and eat it with garlic sauce that's it
nothing else so that's why it from us
brothers and sisters hope to see you
guys taking part as well don't forget
message Imran is the chicken challenge
that's it assalamualaikum what I meant
to lie whatever captain
you